„Ja grüß Gott! Ich bin der Wiesnwirt hier.
Ich bin der Wiesnwirt Wilderer. Es gibt keinen schöneren Beruf als Wiesnwirt, gell?
Obwohl man da auch ganz schön was auf sich nimmt, gell?
Also ich muss wirklich sagen, langsam mag ich nicht mehr.
Zefix! Alles wird teurer. Die Butter wird teurer, die Milch wird teurer,
alles wird teurer. Da wird doch dann das Bier auch mal ein bisschen teurer werden dürfen, nicht?
Wir reißen uns ja eh zusammen.
Wenn ich das alles rechnen würde, was ich für Kosten habe,
dann müsste die Maß Bier auf dem Oktoberfest 20 Euro kosten. 20!
Ich muss doch ein bisschen Geld verlangen dürfen für mein Bier.
Das ist ja eh bloß ein Unkostenbeitrag. Ich kann doch nicht alles herschenken.“
„Papa, kann ich heute den roten Ferrari haben?“
„Ja.“
„Ja, Merci!“
„Das ist auch wieder so ein Fall:
Meinen Sie mein Herr Sohn, dieser Grippe, meinen Sie, der könnte mal den schwarzen Porsche nehmen?
Oder den Daimler oder den Lexus? Alle können sie mir den Buckel runterrutschen!“